tandis qu'une autre sonde avec mika
l'eau commence à regarder on est sur des
sternes un petit jeu en local et vous et
moi on a fait une vidéo à l'époque sur
twitter strike du ca ont lancé des
boules et pas l'esquiver les boules
voilà c'est le même principe payer on y
va de moi je suis là la femme sorcier à
toi tu es jacques le mime donc toi tu
dois me lancer les boules mais qu'elle
est à droit de l'écran ils doivent
lancer des boules et moi je suis à
gauche et je dois esquiver les boules
lalalalalala l'on tient bien train
d'arriver attention attention si l'on
suit je sais pas comment on joue et
j'arrive
j'arrive en haut un peu attention tu
crois tu rêves auxquels furent eux mêmes
sur lui je me serais pas tiré ouais
ouais ouais il relève bon on est là ok
mais quand ça secteur dans ce bal avec
les petites boules de merde kogas et 5e
des petites
oui elles sont horribles et jeannette et
marc gène pas me cacher les boules
tallec l'attaquant de l'équipe s'est
envolé alors je n'en avais en train
d'arriver en train d'arriver
t'es foutu t elle est arrivée bien vite
c'est la pagaille l'histoire connue ce
que tu as chanté alors qu'elle a très
mal chanter ta beauté car des kids
karaté kid au service à temps on n'avait
pas fait ça mais plutôt de boue dans le
visage
c'est faux jamais jamais cette fois à
groupe etex est super dur à cuire doit
faire mal un constat qu'il dresse qui
les sert ouais je restais à dire ouais
malheureusement j'ai 55 secondes pour
finir on va la faire rêver à jouer je
vais faire honneur à mes abonnés
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est squeeze
gaming c'est pas mika gaming au match
aller dans la bonne question de guilde
projet pitbull j'étais vous attends
c'est génial ce genre cette fois ce
facteur a les boules bâtard comment ça
marche
wood a volé mon pote avec ta moan et
christian tu prend cher ou pas dans quoi
ils avalanche de choses de 4 à 10 ans et
c'est le volant mais bon je trouve qu'il
est pris aux 12 heures passées les
petites comme tu coules déjà combien
d'adressés petit comment tu le saurais
génomique un [ __ ] les rennais ne
savais pas que ça faisait mine au début
ouais mais ça c'est qu'à la fin je me
suis foire et la pizza au waf aller ça
t'apprendra c'était juste pour te
prouver que c'est pas si c'est un bâtard
mais mm mais kate avec l'egypte où il
était logé à lescure est ce que ta
copine l'arrivée potentielle d'un aléa
moi je trouverais ball est allé l'année
il habite au mondial qui reste viendra
mixer des routes on sait qu'elle est
chaude
qu'es-tu affaires matar matar il avait
la vie oui oui je suis dégoûté abada à
berne est certes waqif et allez ça
prendra donc semblé mais non mais aller
qu'est ce tu vas faire des cadeaux aux
mécanos on veut tenter des coups mais
pas trop j'avais prévenu mon regard le
maire mais [ __ ] ta mère dans quel
petit à petit
ouais petit à petit l'oiseau france
amine rager plus rien j'ai pu de tous
bords avec j'ai plus de munitions taille
passent tous là je suis en train de
chanter mais cela j'ai plus bouger plus
rien j'ai plus rien je peux rien faire
oui mais non mais non mais non ggc label
ces labels je vais maintenant
minnikhanov ici un mois on doit battre
ce score 3-2 ap à thémines papa papa
papa papa papa on est chauds des choses
et je vois c'est quoi ça m'aide à
trouver des techniques nouvelles quoi o
o palamides pas l'avis de palaminy
sommes pas la barre haut mais [ __ ]
mais basculait nice day nom est ce que
tu vas faire elle allez allez allez
allez allez cette fois je m'en procure
un perfect
y'a un p'tit bout lors le petit blanc du
de l'espoir comme on l'appelle vous
n'aurez pas mais vers des pensées
monsieur mikado c'est qu'ils éprouvent
aussi avec halo la vie non non et non
ses moi j'ai plein chez moi mais
pourquoi sur les marges
j'en ai marre de pita leur jeune âge
dans ses propres trucs quoi
regarde [ __ ] non
non j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus je
faisais en fait ta minh tu l'a tellement
bien milonga [ __ ] ans je vais perdre
mais peut-être aussi parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas une ado ça ne va plus
entre très vite dans une prochaine
[ __ ] montrer notre concept vidéo tient
tout le monde
ouah sacro allait enfin